it was this soon yeah here we go
kristina's catching out i was gonna say
are we getting around us and i'll see
what's happening oh my god should be
amazing i mean come on we've got melissa
mccarthy here this is an snl casting
moment this is an snl casting moment i
mean melissa
when i say the word sean spicer
hopefully the only thing you think of is
melissa mccarthy you know if there's
anything she's done here if there's
if there's anything he's done it's to
motivate her to play him you know yeah
let's talk about you and what you've
done first time nominee tonight how you
feel i feel so honored it's such a i i
don't know it's such a shared
accomplishment with the show and
everyone worked so hard there that it
just feels like i'm like kind of just
representing the whole crew the cast the
writers everybody can we talk about your
fashion are we shirtless underneath the
jackets shirtless underneath the jacket
i mean i don't know if this is what the
people want
this is what this is this is what this
is what's working for me tonight
confirmed it's what the people want
wow okay okay
i got it in my ear wow amazing amazing
um we just had zoe kravitz right who do
you want to have next oh my gosh who
would i want to who do i want to have
next i would love like
a big old pop star someone like
alizzo someone like someone someone
who's maybe on this red carpet i'm not
giving anything away but there might be
people here who might be hosting soon
that's all i'll say right now you know i
do have to ask you pete's going through
a lot right now uh-huh what do you think
of it all and how are you all supporting
him um he is
we're just supporting him by just giving
him space i think i think he's just
you know like
figuring it out because i think a lot is
out of his control maybe in terms of
like people's response and i think he's
just like getting back to his comforts
and i think that's like the best thing
you can do so i think we're all thinking
about him and we love him so much we
can't wait to see you in that fire
island series oh my god i can't wait
it'll be so good yeah i can't wait for
that to come out
i i i like i don't want to like say
anyth too much because i just think i
just want people to go in like not
knowing too much and just enjoying it
yeah
you